une personnalité qui donne une heure de
son temps pour faire partager son métier
avec les plus démunis l'association
habitat et humanisme a organisé un
atelier culinaire à la pension de
famille jouée en josas en présence dé
thierry marx le fait de partager ma
passion et finalement l'écouté là et les
échanges sont deviennent passionnant la
recette du jour pain d'épicés aux pommes
rôties elle avait été élaboré à paris
saclay pour le premier repas de thomas
pesquet dans l'espace objectif apprendre
à travailler les produits et ne pas les
surdoses et j'aimerais qu'ils refassent
mersey déçoit qui comprennent la
philosophie la philosophie de la recette
c'est à dire de ne pas gâcher les
produits qui nous sont données et ne pas
perdre 30% d'une orange ne pas perdre
30% d'une pomme parce qu'on croit que
c'est des déchets alors que c'est des
cons produit et je vais cuiront gradient
descendants
en fait je cuis revit
à l'occasion du passage à l'heure
d'hiver qui a lieu ce dimanche 31
octobre la quatrième édition de leur
solidaire a pour but de lutter contre
l'exclusion et l'isolément des personnes
en difficulté l'objectif auprès des
personnes qui ont participé c'est leur
donner un moment de détente de leur
donner l'occasion aussi d'écouter et
d'apprendre par la voix d'un grand chef
ce qu'ils peuvent ce qu'ils peuvent
faire au total une trentaine de
personnes étaient présentes pour suivre
le cours de cuisine des résidents de la
pension de famille et des locataires des
appartements d'habitat et humanisme
thierry marx était quelqu'un de très
professionnel d'autres très accueillants
et récemment et nous a bien expliqué
comment faut-il procéder pour faire ces
cuisine gastronomique j'ai appris que
des choses que je peux laisser un petit
peu aussi comment vous faire part unique
sont vus là avec les les fruits tout
intéressant parce que je ferai bientôt
toute personne peut participer à cette
opération via la plateforme heures
solidaires.org en faisant un don
d'argent ou bien de temps en
s'inscrivant aux ateliers bénévolat
proposées par l'association